respecto de la línea de tiempo mañana o
el día después se resolverá de manera
técnica decimos ya el acuerdo
el departamento de estado y el
ministerio de exteriores ruso ya han
discutido una serie de temas de
operación diplomática hay mucho por
discutir hay muchas preguntas que se han
sumado creo que ambas partes incluyendo
a los eeuu buscan encontrar terreno
común y encontrar soluciones respecto de
ucrania de hecho tocamos de ese tema nos
diría que tuvimos una conversación muy
larga al respecto pero a lo que respecta
al presidente by the nine lo que entendí
él dijo que la base del acuerdo
ucraniano deben ser el paquete de
medidas de misma
respecto del anexo de ucrania a la otan
hemos tocado este tema
de manera amplia
y no hay mucho por discutir aquí
para la agencia tass
la agencia itar tass por favor de la
palabra
señor presidente usted dijo que uno de
los temas era extraer la estabilidad
estratégica podría usted elaborar sobre
las decisiones en este tema y rusia y
eeuu reanudará no lanzarán negociaciones
sobre estabilidad estratégica y desarme
y particularmente en un nuevo tratado
planean buscar
extensiones
de pronto él
muchas gracias
eeuu y rusia tiene una responsabilidad
especial respecto de la estabilidad
estratégica en el mundo
juzgando a partiendo del hecho de que
somos los mayores pueden nucleares en
términos del número de cabezas nucleares
vehículos de reingreso y métodos de
lanzamiento así mismo como la calidad
y la habilidad de la tecnología estas
armas entendemos esta responsabilidad
del presidente de bailén asumió una
responsabilidad apropiada de extender el
nuevo tratado nuclear por otros cinco
años hasta 2024 realmente la pregunta
aparece que sigue después acordamos que
lanzaríamos empezaríamos consultas a
nivel interagencia
tanto en el departamento de estado de
eeuu y el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de rusia los colegas de
diseñarán el trabajo de estas
delegaciones el lugar de las
negociaciones así como el horario de
estos encuentros la palabra va para cnn
más distante en tanto el martes que
viene de excursión
y eso los hubiera ataques sobre eeuu se
comprometió usted a detener las amenazas
contra la seguridad clínica y
comprometido usted
con dejar de atacar a la oposición en
rusia
respecto de la asesoría en el tema
general yo entiendo que no ha habido
ninguna hostilidad sobre el país nuestro
encuentro
ocurrió lugar de una manera constructiva
tuvimos un asesorías correctas y unos
acuerdos en temas particulares para
ambos lados expresaron sus intenciones
de entenderse o el uno al otro y de
buscar terrenos comunes
las discusiones fueron bastante
productivas y constructivas respecto de
la ciberseguridad acordamos
que iniciaríamos consultas en esos temas
creo que es extremadamente importante
y respecto de las responsabilidades y
quién debería asumir las
déjeme informarlos
los temas que son de conocimiento común
pero posiblemente no todos estén al
tanto
las partes estadounidenses no quieren
los sensores no quieren entrar acá sobre
el nombre de esta organización pero los
eeuu las fuentes estadounidenses
aseguran que la mayoría de ciberataques
son llevados a cabo desde el territorio
estadounidense luego hay un segundo
segundo es canadá luego vienen los
estados y no americanos y luego viene el
reino unido respecto de rusia
no aparece en la lista en este ranking
de países
que percibe en la mayor cantidad de
ciberataques desde su territorio esa es
una cosa en segundo lugar
durante 2020
hemos recibido 10 solicitudes respecto
de ciberataques
ataques sobre la infección
estadounidense
como nuestro nuestros colegas lo
mencionaron los ciberataques fueron
estados desde el territorio ruso y hemos
recibido dos solicitudes este año y de
todas estas solicitudes nuestros colegas
recibieron unas respuestas exhaustivas
rusia envió el año pasado 45 solicitudes
de este tipo a las agencias relevantes
de los eeuu y este año
enviamos 35 y no hubo ninguna respuesta
proveída hasta el momento eso significa
que hay mucho trabajo por hacer respecto
de la escala de las responsabilidades y
quién debería asumir las debe ser
decidido en las negociaciones
posteriores empezamos acordamos iniciar
estas consultas y creemos que el área de
la ciberseguridad es extremadamente
importante en todo el mundo
particularmente para eeuu
así como para la federación rusa de la
misma medida por ejemplo sabemos de
ciberataques en contra del oleoducto de
la organización de los ductos en eeuu y
sabemos que esta compañía
tuvo una pérdida de 5 miles de dólares
de acuerdo con mi información
buscaban devolver algo de este dinero de
billeteras electrónicas pero parte de
este dinero siguen perdidas pero que
deben hacer las autoridades rusas
respecto de eso nosotros enfrentamos
amenazas similares y montañez
cuando se trata de una de las regiones
claves en rusia en su sistema de salud
sabemos de donde lanzan en su cielo
ataque sabemos que sus ciberataques son
coordinados desde los eeuu
yo no creo que las autoridades
estadounidenses estén interesadas en
este tipo de manipulaciones nosotros
debemos liberarnos de este tipo de
insinuaciones de este tipo de matices y
debemos lanzar el trabajo de los
expertos
hemos iniciará este trabajo para el
edificio estados unidos y la federación
rusa vemos hemos llegado a un acuerdo en
principio pero si está listo
rt
por favor del micrófono
creo que parte de la pregunta no fue
respondida
la primera es se comprometió usted en
estas reuniones a detener la amenaza
sobre ucrania recuerda que la razón para
esta cumbre la de rusia estaba
aumentando las fuerzas cerca a ucrania y
la segunda parte de la tercera parte
se comprometió usted a acabar sus
ataques contra los grupos de oposición
dentro de rusia como el xxi no ha ni
bueno para ser honesto esta parte de la
pregunta no fue interpretada o
posiblemente usted decidió hacer una
segunda parte de la pregunta pero
respecto
de los compromisos con ucrania no
tenemos un solo compromiso y es ayudar y
facilitar la implementación del acuerdo
de minsk si está dispuesto a hacerlo
nosotros estamos listos para seguir ese
camino sin duda alguna
y quiero llamar atención sobre un tema
en noviembre de 2020 la de creación
ucraniana presentó sus ideas sobre cómo
pretendía implementar los acuerdos de
minsk
y no es un documento confidencial se
estipula que en primer lugar las
propuestas de la integración política
del donbass al sistema legal ucraniano
deben ser presentadas
así como la constitución
deben venderse a la constitución eso se
estipula y en primer lugar segundo lugar
las fronteras entre rusia y ucrania
la línea del donbass
esas situaciones de seguridad deben ser
facilitadas después de elecciones en el
artículo 9 que propuso rusia como primer
paso
propuso regresar las retornar las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas a sus zonas
de estacionamiento significa que las
fuerzas armadas deberían
ser desplegadas en el primer punto en un
lugar buscan cerrar la frontera
ruso-ucraniana en esta área en tercer
lugar buscan sostener elecciones tres
veces después de que estos dos pasos
sean cumplidos
no no debe ser ahogado ni debe tener una
experiencia particular para entender que
eso no tiene nada que ver con el acuerdo
de mix que contradice completamente los
acuerdos de ming ming entonces qué tipo
de obligaciones adicionales debería
rusia asumir yo creo que la respuesta es
bastante clara respecto de los
ejercicios
que se están llevando a cabo en el
territorio así como eeuu hace respecto
de muchos otros ejercicios
nosotros no llevamos a cabo nuestros
ejercicios desplegando equipo militar
cerca a las fronteras de esta audiencia
así afortunadamente
la fuerte es afortunadamente eso es lo
que hacen los socios estadounidenses con
nuestra frontera nosotros tenemos estas
preocupaciones ellos no la tienen pero
este es el tema de discusión y un tema
de clarificar posiciones respecto con
este sistema en esa posición no
sistémica
y el ciudadano que usted ha mencionado
en primer lugar esta persona sabía
completamente que violaba la ley
existente en rusia
y él debía entender que era una persona
qué bueno ofendí a repetidamente a esta
ley el biólogo deliberadamente esta ley
él salió del país a recibir tratamiento
médico
y una vez
salió del hospital y publicó sus vídeos
en internet
hubo una
y una solicitud pero él ignoró esa
solicitud de la ley
y esa vía completamente que era una
persona buscada sin embargo decidió
volver a rusia deliberadamente quiso ser
arrestado entonces él hizo lo que quería
hacer qué podemos decir acá respecto de
personas como él y la posición es
sistémica desafortunadamente el formato
de la rueda de prensa no nos permite
tener una conversación detallada sobre
este tema pero déjeme decir lo siguiente
yo creo que es bastante simple y esto
será claro sería claro para cualquier
persona
si ustedes simplemente pudieran tener
una cobertura no sesgada esto yo lo
apreciarían así que los eeuu declararon
que rusia era su enemigo y su adversario
el congreso lo hizo en 2017
la legislación posterior tiene
previsiones de que los eeuu
deberán respaldar el orden
y el el estado de derecho en nuestro
país y las organizaciones democráticas
todo está en toda esta esta legislación
hagamos esa pregunta si rusia realmente
es un enemigo qué tipo de organizaciones
estarían respaldando serían los que
refiere el respaldo de eeuu en rusia
yo creo que estas no son organizaciones
que hagan que rusia sea más fuerte sino
aquellos que disuaden a rusia esa es la
mesa de eeuu esa es la meta pública de
eeuu estas organizaciones y estas
personas que ayudan a implementar las
políticas estadounidenses en el
territorio estadounidense en el
territorio ruso
cuál debería ser nuestra posición al
respecto
creo claramente que debemos ser
cautelosos
pero
actuaremos en la ley rusa
darchinyan
vamos a volver con el micrófono
quiero hacer seguimiento sobre este tema
los estadounidenses siguen sosteniendo
esta retórica de prisioneros políticos
se produce a ellos le dan fuego a esto
tú discutieron el tema de naval y
durante las discusiones y si lo hicieron
en qué tono una segunda pregunta también
estamos viendo una nueva etapa de la
relación rusa estadounidense empezó con
una declaración más bien agresiva
con la descripción de bailén suya
el presidente by del sí tocó el tema de
los derechos humanos y el tema de
personas que ellos consideran
bueno que están cercanas a este tema de
discutimos esto es último las
declaraciones agresivas también las
escuchamos
y él me dijo justo después del inicio
él explicó lo que quería decir y yo tuve
estuve bien con lo que él dijo esta fue
su iniciativa nosotros nos encontramos y
de nuevo la conversación fue bastante
constructiva y de nuevo entendí que el
presidente by the end es un estadista
experimentado nuestra conversación uno a
uno como alrededor de dos horas
no está en cada líder mundial
bueno ningún líder mundial recibe este
tipo de atención su predecesor recibió
la misma pregunta y el radio este
presidente decidió responder a la
pregunta directamente y esto lo hace muy
diferente al presidente de trump
pero mire lo de esta manera todo lo que
sucede en nuestros países es algo que el
liderazgo político debe ser su sueño
como responsable incluyendo a los
presidentes
desde esa perspectiva
este es el trato estadounidense la gente
está así entonces sin nada ya incluyendo
aquellos
que están liderando
en varios proyectos organizaciones
políticas ellos pueden recibir balas en
la cabeza
una mujer acaba de huir de la policía y
le dispararon por la espalda
miren afganistán por ejemplo uno solo
ataque puede matar más de 200 personas
asumido que esto fue un error sucede
sucedió en guerra
pero hacer un disparo desde un drone a
una multitud desarmada claramente una
multitud civil que es esto como se le
llama a esto y quién es el responsable y
cómo se llamaría esta persona quién es
el asesino ahora volvamos al registro al
tema de los derechos humanos esta
prisión de guantánamo sigue operando ni
siquiera se parece a lo que se estipuló
en la ley internacional o en la ley
estadounidense aún así existe
y las prisiones secretas de la cia están
en todo el mundo incluyendo en países
europeos donde la gente fue torturada
esto es un buen registro de derechos
humanos yo lo dudo bastante alguien
accord estaría de acuerdo con que si se
protegen los derechos humanos esto
afecta bastante en el terreno esta es la
realidad de la política hoy y nosotros
entendemos que así es como se ha hecho y
basados en eso respondemos
cuando la gente reciba patrocinio desde
el exterior para defender la agenda
oculta de aquellos que los patrocinan
de nuevo una pregunta sobre el artículo
usted mencionó una inquietud de aquí los
eeuu han estado acusando rusia de
militarizar el artículo también lo dicen
los aliados estadounidenses en marzo el
secretario de estado- blinken hizo voz
de su preocupación que discutieron en
detalle bueno hemos discutido esto
si nuestros asistentes presentes hubo
una sensación particular es decir la
exploración del ártico en general
es de bastante interés para muchos
países no solamente para nosotros y eeuu
entonces si eeuu sin preocupaciones pero
no tienen ningún fundamento de estas
preocupaciones por la militarización no
tiene ningún fundamento no estamos
haciendo nada nuevo simplemente estamos
restaurando la infraestructura que ya
había estado ahí estamos estamos
rearmando estamos queriendo
revitalizando la infraestructura
fronteriza
pero también preocupados por la
conservación del medio ambiente y
también la infraestructura de búsqueda y
rescate estamos incrementando la
posibilidad de salvar personas en el mar
si eso llega a suceder
estamos proteger al buscado proteger al
medio ambiente he dicho a nuestros
colegas que no hubo ninguna razón para
preocuparse totalmente lo opuesto creo
que hay muchas posibilidades de
cooperación y deberíamos cooperar en
este sentido
después de todo rusia y eeuu son los
mayores miembros del consejo del ártico
rusia está feliz rusia estuvo a la
presidencia el consejo del ártico este
año incluso más
como ustedes posiblemente saben hubo una
intercambio entre alaska y oscar un lado
eeuu en otro rusia todo eso ha sumido
unido nos debería llevar a trabajar
juntos a redoblar los esfuerzos
y el uso de la ruta del mar del norte
su uso es regulado por el internacional
hay dos grandes regulaciones esa es la
ley del mar en las naciones unidas
que se tiene desde 1980 y son varios
documentos de eso fue ratifico eso fue
ratificado en 1917 bueno hay un marco
legal yo llamé la atención de nuestras
contrapartes sobre este marco legal y
sobre el hecho de que nosotros rusia
estamos completamente listos para
defender las regulaciones existentes no
hemos infringido ninguna de estas
regulaciones estamos preparados para dar
una mano de ayuda a todos los países y
compañías que quieren explorar las
posibilidades del mar del norte ahora
que la navegación está abierta estuviera
por medio año pero incluso es más que
eso
bueno a medida que nuestro país nuestro
planeta se caliente estas vías estarán
más abiertas todo el año nuevos
rompehielos incluyendo nuestros nuevos
rompehielos están dispuestos tenemos la
ma la plata más fuerte de rompehielos
del mundo esto comprueba
la demanda de la demanda del uso del mar
del norte ahora la ley del mar de las
naciones unidas- describe y establecen
el marco legal
trini muera
alrededor de estas aguas internacionales
las aguas territoriales de cada país y
mares adyacentes
zonas económicas exclusivas
y la libertad del marco de los males
internos vi que es eso
esos son los mares que está en el
interior de los auditorios soberanos de
un país luego el mar territorial hay 12
millas hay mar adyacente 12 millas más
en términos de los mares adyacentes de
los países sin duda debería haber un
derecho de paso libre e incluso a las
naves militares hay objeciones no las
hacemos ahora los mares internos e
interiores son diferentes no estamos
obligados a proveerle a nadie nada
pero tengan en mente eso el territorio
de los mares interiores los cinco que
hay el de ocs
bueno hay varios territorios en la bahía
de escoja algunos otros la longitud de
esto
es cerca de 1000 millas náuticas
es un derecho soberano del que
disfrutamos sea que queramos o no dar el
derecho a pasaje pero no estamos
abusando de este derecho nada más el año
pasado tuvimos mil solicitudes para
hacer el cruce y creo que solamente
rechazamos 1010 solicitudes y la mayoría
de ellas pertenecen a naves que tiene la
bandera rusa y las agencias reguladoras
dijeron que no podían cumplir con los
códigos polares el código polar definen
detalla los requerimientos para las
naves que están cruzando los mares
entonces tenemos todo esto junto los
estados actores los miembros
del consejo del nórdico ya podemos hacer
muchas cosas buenos juntos hay muchas
preocupaciones hay muchas posibilidad de
contradicción pero creo
pero hay un tema que no podamos resolver
si no tenemos un esfuerzo con un
esfuerzo fuerte
buenas tardes señor presidente
las buenas relaciones no malas siempre
eeuu más o menos siempre ha sido la
garantía
de la estabilidad en el mundo lo que
usted acaba de decir del acuerdo con
bailén se habla de un mutuo respeto de
los terrenos comunes hay algo que pueda
caracterizar más esta reunión hablan
ustedes de líneas rojas pero los
estadounidenses tienen líneas nuevas
también en este punto acordaron ustedes
como no cruzar las líneas rojas
al hacer este acuerdo mejora mejoraron o
deterioran las relaciones
va a ponerlo de esta manera nosotros
entendemos
lo que nuestros socios estadounidenses
sin hacer ellos entienden lo que
nosotros estamos diciendo cuando decimos
que esto es una línea roja
pero voy a dejarlo muy claro no hemos
llegado al punto en el que definimos
líneas específicas
pero hemos llegado de acuerdos para
trabajar juntos para seguir y avanzar en
temas de seguridad es estabilidad
estratégica y también creo que durante
estas consultas
nuestro esfuerzo común en el ártico eso
nos permitirá detallar los trazar los
detalles noticias abc por favor
presidente baiden ha dicho que él
respondería a los ciberataques de
renuncia si no se detiene
me genera curiosidad que le dijo ellis o
alguna amenaza y hay un seguimiento
pequeño que quisiera hacer el señor la
lista de oponentes políticos que están
muertos en prisión o en
aleshin naval y su organización pidió
elecciones libres sin lo más corrupción
pero rusia ha dicho que esa organización
es extremista ilegal y usted ha impedido
que cualquiera que lo respalde aspira a
algún cargo entonces me pregunta del
señor presidente a qué le tiene miedo
bueno simplemente quiero reiterar lo que
acabo de decir sobre
los supuestos agentes foráneos
hay gente que se retrata como
composición no sistémica bueno creo que
yo yo he respondido a las preguntas de
cnn pero creo que estas son las reglas
del juego
yo tengo que reiterarlo lo voy a
reiterar está bien no puedo no tengo
ningún problema
los eeuu tienen una ley que dice que los
estados unidos- respaldarán de manera
específica entidades organizaciones en
rusia a la vez la federación rusa fue
detallada como un adversario fue
definida como un adversario lo dijeron
está en el registro dijeron públicamente
que ellos tendrían el desarrollo de
rusia esa es la pregunta qué tipo de
organizaciones
son respaldadas por estados unidos y por
el oeste que reciben dinero patrocinios
si somos considerados adversarios es
bastante claro que como los eeuu en los
30 de nosotros
los beta no los vendamos pero dijimos
que eran agentes foráneos
y si ustedes lo llaman un agente foráneo
no le dicen que le dice que no puedo
parar en el país esta organización
terrorista y esa es una historia
completamente diferente a la
organización
a pedido de manera pública desorden
público y caos de manera abierta ha
instruido ha dicho a las personas sobre
cómo hacer cócteles mólotov para usarlos
en contra de las fuerzas de la ley ellos
han solicitado
américa facción nos dábamos
la presencia de personas menores de edad
en los maitines eeuu acaba de pasar por
una lamentable cadena de eventos después
de que el cierto individuo ha prestado
unidense fue asesinado
y apareció un movimiento black lifemiles
no voy a entrar en detalles
voy a ahorrarles los detalles pero hemos
visto pogroms
hemos visto saqueos hemos visto
violación hemos visto desmanes nosotros
estamos en simpatía con los
estadounideses pero no queremos que lo
mismo pase en el territorio ruso y
haremos todo lo posible para impedir que
eso suceda y eso no se trata de mis
temores si usted quiere pensar en eso
en el presente juicio
y bueno respecto de mis oponentes en cae
en la prisión
la gente fue al congreso de eeuu con
demandas políticas 400 personas ahora
están enfrentando cargos criminales
ellos están enfrentando
sentencias de prisión de hasta 20 25
años se les llama terroristas
locales se les llama muchas cosas
70 personas fueron arrestadas justo ahí
mismo
30 de ellos siguen arrestados bajo qué
pretexto no es claro es decir ninguna de
las autoridades oficiales de los estados
nos han informado respecto de eso así
que realmente no lo sabemos
uno de los participantes una mujer
recibe un disparo y murió en el lugar
ella no estaba amenazando con armas a
nadie ni nada
porque doy esto a conocer mucha gente
está enfrentando lo mismo que nosotros
hacemos y yo estoy insistiendo en esto
estamos en simpatía con los eeuu pero no
queremos
que lo mismo se repite en el territorio
ruso un par de preguntas más por favor
y bueno llegó a algún acuerdo con eeuu
sobre el regreso de ciertos ciudadanos
rusos que están entre prisiones de
estados unidos y si ese fuera el caso
que podría suceder si nosotros hablamos
de este tema y el presidente bailén dijo
esto respecto de los ciudadanos
estadounidenses que están actualmente en
prisiones rusas discutimos esto puede
haber algún territorio para llegar a un
compromiso pero eeuu y el departamento
de estado de entrar en esa dirección
canal atv buenos días
rusia usted dijo que quería discutir el
comercio que el presidente by the end y
puede que eso sea uno de los puntos
impositivos de las comunidades
comerciales que cooperación de ambos
lados cuáles son los prospectos de
cooperación
bueno eso no depende nosotros sino de
los eeuu nosotros no impusimos ninguna
restricción creo
que después de imponer ciertas
restricciones económicas
eeuu perdió tanto como fusiones
realmente de alguna manera afectó a
nuestro desarrollo hasta cierto punto y
hasta cierto punto los estados unidos
simplemente logró su meta de disuadir a
rusia y su desarrollo pero
no hay nada particularmente importante
ahí el segundo el interés de la
comunidad comercial de eeuu
los eeuu tenían la mayor delegación en
el foro económico de san petersburgo 200
personas respecto de las restricciones
en contra las compañías estadounidenses
algunas compañías de estadounidenses
perdieron su presencia en reducción y se
dieron su negocio a sus rivales porque
no tienen ningún propósito pero tienen
pérdidas
nuestro comercio con eeuu estaba en
cerca de 28 mil dólares por el primer
cuarto de este año creció en un 16%
creo que si esa tendencia perfil
persiste venecia beneficiará a todos y
hemos discutido ese tema saben algo
recibir un par de preguntas más de este
lado y un par de preguntas del otro lado
si la dama
y hace unos cuantos años de usted
conoció el presidente wyden y él era el
vicepresidente y él dijo que miro a sus
ojos y que no había visto un alma y
usted dijo eso significa que nos
entendemos podría usted decir si miro a
sus ojos y que vio aquí voy a usted o
una persona con la cual podría trabajar
y por favor dígame si el presidente
bailén lo ha invitado a la casa blanca y
si ese es el caso acordó usted ir bueno
el primer presidente wyden no me invitó
a ir y yo no
he hecho una unificación relevante de mi
parte creo que para que tales encuentros
tales visitas ocurren debería haber
condiciones
qué bueno consejos correctas respecto de
mirar a los ojos ver el arma no estamos
viendo nada bueno es la primera vez que
escucho esto y para ser honesto no
recuerdo haber tenido tal conversación
pero asumo que eso pudo haber sucedido
si usted me pregunta qué tipo de persona
e interlocutor es el presidente baile yo
debo decir que es una persona
constructiva una persona balanceada con
mucha experiencia un político
experimentado yo esperaba eso
él
recuerdo a su familia
las conversaciones que tuvo con su madre
bueno estas cosas
no tienen nada que ver directamente con
nuestros temas y nuestros santos pero
sin embargo eso muestra sus cualidades
sus valores morales
y todo fue muy llamativo y creo que
nosotros ya hablamos en el mismo
lenguaje
no significa necesariamente que debamos
mirarnos a los ojos y vernos el alma
las extranjeros
y prometer algún tipo de amor eterno
nosotros defendemos nuestros intereses
nacionales
y esta relación siempre está basada en
el pragmatismo
android plis
soy andrade kolésnikov periódico
kommersant ser presidente tras esta
reunión estar usted alguna ilusión
alguna ilusión reciente nueva yo no
tenía realmente viejas ilusiones ahora
tampoco tengo las nuevas no ha habido
ninguna ilusión es
pasemos a este lado
en la parte de atrás por favor den el
micrófono a
a la dama
bueno buenos días soy el presidente
tengo dos preguntas si pudiera respecto
del cambio climático global discutieron
esto con el presidente bailen en segundo
lugar respecto de los medios
estadounidenses recientemente usted
tiene una gran entrevista al canal en
visita
es justo que usted de entrevista a los
medios estadounidenses y los presidentes
estadounidenses no le dan entrevistas a
nuestros medios rusos ve usted un
impacto positivo tras esta entrevista si
sus palabras resultan ser siempre
distorsionadas
y no es tratado de manera respetable
bueno respecto de las distorsiones y
malas interpretaciones
y esa es la práctica de las relaciones
internacionales acá y no hay nada que
hacer al respecto yo me acostumbré ya he
vivido con esto por décadas ya
respecto de las entrevistas
y quien da esas entrevistas realmente
eso depende de las decisiones de los
líderes si él quiere enviar un mensaje
al pueblo nosotros intentaremos hacerlo
nosotros intentamos hacerlo esa es la
esencia de mis entrevistas a los medios
estadounidenses respecto de las
actividades de nuestros medios por
ejemplo el presidente by the end
y menciona sus preocupaciones sobre el
trabajo
soy somos ni el grupo fue así
el trabajo de radio radio frío miró que
nosotros declaramos como agentes
foráneos yo tuve la impresión de que los
miembros de la delegación estadounidense
no estaban al tanto
antes de eso realmente tuvimos dos
medios
y que transmiten para audiencias
internacionales
ellos lo declararon como agentes
internacionales y también los despojaron
de su acreditación lo que yo hice fue
una restauración y a la vez
cumple todos los requerimientos de la
regulación estadounidense está
registrado
aunque enfrentan algunos problemas
respecto del contra también de la
contratación de personales y las
transacciones financieras pero nosotros
bueno yo no tienen ese tipo de problemas
y los medios estadounidenses no cumplen
la ley rusa
nosotros vamos a conocer nuestra opinión
y nosotros esperamos que se pueda esto
trabajar en términos de ministerios de
relaciones exteriores yo realmente
quería que una mujer hiciera una
pregunta muchas gracias que el inapa lom
se podría usted si lleve news todos
sabíamos todos vimos como usted sacudió
las manos con este hecho humano es el
presidente hoy en llegar a otro nivel de
entendimiento mutuo y hay confianza
cree usted que es realista considera en
este punto que llegamos a un nuevo nivel
de las relaciones que puedan ser
totalmente claro transparente esa es la
meta final de estos dos países
bueno leon tolstoi dijo alguna vez que
no hay felicidad en la vida solamente
hay una pequeña parte y hay que
apreciarla y creo que aquí
no podemos sentir ningún tipo de
confianza final pero veo que hay algunos
brillos de confianza alguna posibilidad
y el 19 es uno de los temas claves a
kalou este discutido al respecto durante
el encuentro si ese es el caso cuáles
son los prospectos de el trabajo
conjunto con los colegas de eeuu para
superar la pandemia
posiblemente podemos hablar del
reconocimiento muto de vacunas bueno
nosotros hablamos de eso pero fue breve
bueno en mi en los momentos en las
administraciones anteriores nosotros
aceptamos las peticiones de eeuu y
enviamos nuestros equipos como parte de
la asistencia humanitaria
no es que ellos no tengan dinero es que
en ese punto estaban en una necesidad
inmediata de ventiladores nosotros lo
hicimos de una manera voluntaria estamos
listos para hacer esa cooperación pero
no hemos discutido esta en detalle musli
el distrito después del encuentro con el
presidente de trump las relaciones se
han deteriorado entre nuestros dos
países hay algunos factores que podrían
digamos decir que esto no va a suceder a
partir de hoy
ha llegado un punto al fondo la relación
bueno yo debo de decir que todas las
acciones relacionadas con la
deterioración de la relación entre rusia
y eeuu fueron iniciadas por eeuu una por
rusia
los congresistas son bastante creativos
y yo realmente no sé que inventaran
dejen adelante
a dónde vamos
soy alexander gama de como pravda sabes
que rusia le ganó al equipo finlandés de
10 es cierto felicitaciones
si nosotros asumimos esta misma
habilidad después de esta reunión cuál
es el marcador quién ganó
en la segunda parte de la pregunta antes
de venir a ginebra los estadounidenses
estaban diciendo que van a ejercer
presión sobre putin es sin que usted
esta presión y como usted la recisión
creo que toda rusia está pensando en
como nuestro presidente le fue creo que
es suficiente pregunta eso estoy de
acuerdo es más que suficiente no sentí
ninguna presión en absoluto fue una
conversación franca y cándida
sin salirnos de los temas que nos
convocaban sin perder la atención como
dije ni nosotros ni los eeuu han
intentado de ejercer ningún tipo de
presión pero éste no era el punto del
encuentro y el marcador bueno el
marcador yo creo que antes de
encontrarnos con el presidente bailen
bueno esta no es una competición iván no
es una competencia y yo realmente bueno
vamos a establecer realmente un marcador
no esa fue una reunión fructífera esta
no fue una significativa y tuvo lugar
una atmósfera que nos permitía crear y
lograr avances lo más importante son los
pequeños brillos de confianza y
esperanza que tuvimos
bbc por favor
ah
señor presidente joe biden pidió
relaciones estables y predecibles con
rusia sin embargo el oeste cree que la
libertad sin predictibilidad es una
característica rusa en la política está
listo para abandonar la inestabilidad
para mejorar la relación con el oeste
bueno es una gran compilación y es
difícil realmente seguir esta lógica yo
envidio mucho su manera de pensar es
como una contradicción de términos usted
dice que el oeste cree y luego la
segunda parte
está usted listo para dejar ir esto
bueno si el oeste cree esto no significa
que esa sea la realidad objetiva déjeme
enfrentar su pregunta por parte para
detallar la usted cree que el oeste cree
que la política rusa es impredecible
bueno de gms recíproco en respecto
pero este es el retiro de tratado abm en
eso fue impredecible porque harían eso y
acabar con las bases de la estabilidad
estratégica ahora hubo una retirada otro
teatre u otro retiro en 2019 el acuerdo
de 'cielos abiertos'
eso también acabó con la estabilidad
así que no hay patas para que esta mesa
se sostenga
esperemos afortunadamente el tratado
nuclear fue conservado y el presidente
bojan ha tomado una decisión sabia al
extenderlo por cinco años a extenderlo
por cinco años más ahora sabemos la
situación alrededor de ucrania en
ucrania en crimea aquí fue donde todo
empezó a cierto miren déjeme hacerle una
pregunta que era estable
cuando se respaldaba a un golpe estado
en ucrania el presidente yanukóvych
estaba listo para anunciar nuevas
elecciones él había acordado hacerlo con
todas las demandas pero no no no había
que ir con un golpe de estado
las clasificaciones posteriores de
crimea el este de ucrania usted está
diciendo que nosotros estamos buscando
la inestabilidad y la verdad es que no
lo creo
en mi cabeza vemos las cosas diferentes
no pensamos en estos términos nosotros
creamos creemos que estamos intentando
crear estabilidad pero para que la
situación sea estable necesitamos
establecer un acuerdo reglas de conducta
en todas las áreas la estabilidad
estratégica la ciberseguridad el
conflicto regional
y lo que yo creo es que podemos llegar a
un acuerdo y podemos llegar a un acuerdo
en estos temas
por favor cerremos esto abre el
micrófono por favor
kenny
hay canciones populares hagamos eso
digamos algo inteligente inteligible
entendible bloomberg y cerramos después
de bloomberg
en la última pregunta
bloomberg news el archivo en 2016
después de encontrarse con el presidente
de trump usted dijo que las sanciones
bueno una nueva ronda de sanciones
estadounidenses compuesta que he pasado
en esta ronda de negociaciones hubo
alguna tranquilidad respecto a que no
habría nuevas sanciones en el futuro
próximo
provenientes de los estados unidos y
usted también habló de estos pequeños
brillos de esperanza que tiene usted
algún tipo de idea sobre lo posible de
que el presidente baile siga con estas
promesas de que se cree que el aparato
político estadounidense está mostrando
más solidaridad con el presidente white
en que al presidente trump se ha llegado
a un acuerdo en consulta sobre
ciberseguridad sobre ucrania cree usted
que habrá un tipo de grupo de trabajo
establecido creo cree usted que habrá
líneas rojas que serán respetadas
trazadas
creo que he discutido el tema de las
líneas rojas es bastante
usted ve
que la confianza de estas charlas parte
de las negociaciones no hay razón de que
nos encontremos y nos amen hacemos bien
que cambiemos ataques verbales ese no es
el punto
las restricciones las sanciones son algo
que de lo cual he hablado no sabemos qué
es lo que está cociéndose en el aparato
político estadounidense es decir
nosotros sabemos la parte amplia pero no
conocemos los detalles que posiblemente
hay oponentes opositores y proponentes
de desarrollar mejores relaciones con
rusia quien prevalecerá es difícil de
decir esperemos que se tomen pasos
después de esta cumbre esto esperemos
bueno alguno yo lo pensaría pero eso
sólo significaría que es una oportunidad
perdida si sucede la última pregunta
nadie
y antes que nada
y usted dijo algunos de mis colegas que
usted quería
una presencia sin cercos pueda de
traducción me escucha bien ahora
puedo hablar en ruso
no estoy escuchando la traducción
un grupo de aprovechar
action
[Música]
por favor repita la pregunta
y usted le dijo a algunos de mis colegas
que usted quería
preguntas sin sesgo justas y tengo una
pregunta justa que viene de mi hija de
nueve años me
pregunto antes de venir de qué se
trataba cuál es el problema cuál es el
tema de esta cumbre es una pregunta de
una niña de nueve años yo quisiera que
usted me explicará en sus propias
palabras señor presidente porque estas
relaciones están complicadas y también
ella quisiera saber y yo también
quisiera saber por qué la gente joven no
puede protestar en rúsia
y
bueno es algo increíble que su niña de 9
años está interesada en esto la
respuesta es bastante simple
usted tiene que mirar a su alrededor y
ver
pensar para sí que es un mundo
maravilloso
la gente que crece los adultos líderes
de dos grandes países y de los grandes
poderes nucleares se encuentran para
intentar hacer que ese mundo sea un
lugar más seguro
un lugar más próspero para que todos
vivan para que muchas personas de todo
el mundo vivan bien estas dos personas
discuten todo este tema de las armas
horribles que nos pueden matar a todos y
que de alguna manera deben ser prevenida
de esta violencia de estos hombres
discutirán la naturaleza
cómo hacer que los ríos sean más limpios
cómo hacer que los mares sean más
limpios cómo impedir las inundaciones y
las sequías y cómo asegurarse que todo
el mundo tenga suficiente comida en
todas partes del mundo qué más se puede
discutir la salud la medicina para que
cuando los niños crezcan y estén bien de
salud para que puedan estudiar aquí
tengan un futuro brillante y deseo con
todo mi corazón que eso sea así
este encuentro debería ser cubierto con
estas ideas en mente muchas gracias